joining us now from Greater Manchester
is the party of shadow community
secretary Andrew Gwyn thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning I get to Labour's policy on
brexit I just wanted to get your view on
the story dominating the newspapers
today about the police being called to
be Boris Johnson's flat is this a cause
for concern or is this something that is
a private matter
that we should draw a line under well in
one sense of course it is a private
matter but when you're running for
public office when you are wanting to be
the Prime Minister of the United Kingdom
then these matters are in the public
interest and you know I've long held the
view that Boris Johnson is unsuitable to
be prime minister of this country I mean
I've had my run-ins with Boris I
infamously was almost tackled to the
ground in the 2017 general election by
this man but you know I just think his
record throughout his time both as Mayor
of London wasting money on the garden
bridge wasting money on Routemaster
buses wasting money on water cannon that
couldn't be used through to his
disastrous tenure as foreign secretary
just renders him completely
I think unsuitable to be the prime
minister of our great country
okay well we'll be hearing more from a
support for Boris Johnson later it does
feel as if people are very keen to kind
of give him the kicking this morning on
the program and let's move on to
Labour's position on the second
referendum this is something I know that
a lot of our viewers will be very
interested in so can you just outline
has there been a change and what is the
position now well there has been a
change in the sense that we recognize
coming out of the European elections and
into the Tory leadership contest that we
are probably facing a hard right Tory
prime minister who will want to run down
the clock to no deal and let's be very
clear Sophie the Labour Party has always
said that we are against a no deal
brexit okay
many times I'm just trying to get to the
bottom as to whether the Labour Party
position has shifted is the party now in
favor of a second referendum in all
circumstances well Jeremy said that and
that is because we face the risk of no
deal so that any brexit deal that is
brought to Parliament including a No
Deal scenario we will say as the Labour
Party that there should be a second
referendum on those prospects because
you know it's looking increasingly
likely that we're heading to No Deal
that was not on the ballot paper in 2016
it is a real risk to the NHS it is a
real risk to manufacturing industry and
I represent a constituency in Greater
Manchester that is still heavily reliant
on manufacturing industry and it is a
huge risk to the security of our country
because it tears up all of those
security relationships that we have with
Europol and euro just and the european
arrest warrant and these are things that
people who voted to leave did not vote
to be made less safe and to have their
country plunged off a cliff when you
talk about your own constituency there
which of course voted to leave the EU
and i just want to ask you about
something that you wrote recently after
the local elections you said in this
piece it's clear from the reaction on
the doorstep that the talk about another
referendum was a difficult message to
explain to many of our traditional
voters is it a difficult message and you
were concerned that perhaps some of your
colleagues representing London seats
that voted to remain don't appreciate
what a difficult message it is in some
parts of the country it's an incredibly
difficult message because look at the
end of the day we put a question to the
people and we got an answer in 2016 and
Parliament has tried to negotiate its
way through the mess that the government
has created we set out what we thought
could be reasonable terms for a brexit
deal that would command a majority in
the House of Commons but
times past you know we are not going to
get Labor's brexit deal presented by
Prime Minister Johnson or Prime Minister
Hunt and so the the realization is that
whatever they come back to Parliament
with between now and October we have to
go back to the people and we have to say
is this really the brexit that you want
and I'm keen to talk to you about some
of the domestic agenda as well there's a
report that was commissioned by the
Labour Party published on its website
called land for many it's received some
attention over the last week or say so I
just want to try to get to the bottom of
whether or not this is policy that you
are actively considering one of the
things that it references in this report
in the men on Sunday today is about
dropping the capital gains tax exemption
on family homes so in other words you if
you if you you know made over a certain
amount when you sell your home that
would be taxed is that something that
Labour's considering no look this this
report it's an important report it's
independent of the Labour Party it's
been submitted to the Labour Party as
part of our policy considerations in our
deliberations there are some interesting
ideas in that report but none of it
forms labour policy we've got national
Policy Forum processes to go through
we've got annual conference to go
through these are the bodies that set
policy alongside the Shadow Cabinet and
this report will help inform some of
those decisions as we go forward but
absolutely the ideas in that report are
not Labour Party policy another idea in
the report is that potential potentially
replacing inheritance tax with something
called a lifetime gift tax so all gifts
that you give your children over a
lifetime over a certain amount would be
taxed rather than just in the seven
years before your death can you rule
that out
look it's exactly the same answer it's a
report that's been submitted
independently to the Labour Party it
will go through the policy making
processes but it's the Shadow Cabinet
it's the National Policy Forum and its
annual conference that actually
determines what our policy is these are
ideas that have been submitted
independently they are not Labour Party
policy okay and rakuen thank you very
much for coming on the program this
morning thank you